foreign
[Music]
set lights camera action 10 minute
okay D4
the play king's Linda on defense okay
because I feel like playing my opinion
so the play very much Kings Indian
defense okay till six okay F4 very
interesting Four Points attack yes
okay so this is the four pawns attack of
the king's Indian defense which is one
of the most dangerous lines and one of
the most underrated lines for white it's
a line that you'll get absolutely blown
off the board with black if you don't
know virtually all of the theories so we
begin by castling
and historically there are two moves in
this position that I have played
throughout my career one of them is this
rare line where black actually goes E5
anyway
sounds totally absurd but it's very
possible and we're gonna try that here
E5 is a very underestimated sideline
that a lot of players don't know and it
throws a lot of players off immediately
okay F6 C5 D5 this is of course a
sacrifice so white could play Knight 65
but it's not very advisable to play
Knight takes E5 who can tell me why how
do we we need to induce weaknesses in
White Center right playing a move like
rookie 8 is not effective because rookie
8 doesn't threaten anything so we need
to inflect White spawn structure we need
to induce weaknesses the best way to do
that is to use our pawns if we play
Knight C6 we're just allowing white and
out right Knight takes C6 so of course
we need to play the typical Kings Indian
move C5 this is where my theoretical
knowledge Ends by the way so now we're
on our own
the point of C5 is to get the d54 pawn
to move why are we getting the D4 pawn
move what is the D4 Pawn defending it's
defending the Knight why is the Knight
important because the Knight is being
x-rayed by the bishop it's in the center
of everything it's vulnerable to rookie
eight to Knight takes C4 to all sorts of
tactics if it's undefended and that's
why we have to make it undefended at all
costs
so for those watching YouTube we're
making an exception doing a 10 minute
game for this speedrun episode just
because I've got a morning interview and
got to go to bed on time so I'll try to
make this worth your while nonetheless
but obviously I will be playing a little
bit faster I will be my explanations
will be a little bit more terse during
the game but we'll still do a
post-mortem analysis and hopefully I'll
make this worth your worth your while
yeah D5 okay so D5 is totally reasonable
and here we have a fork in the road we
can if we want to win the pawn back take
on e4 we can play Knight takes C4
Knight takes E4 then maybe we can throw
in a check on H4
force that Knight back and then
recapture the Knight on E5 with what
seems to be a very nice position the
alternative is to play Rook E8 and try
to
throw the Knight off of E5 and develop
immediate pressure down the e-file both
options look very appealing to me let's
go for the traditional idea let's play
Rook E8 and let's try to develop massive
pressure on the e-file before white has
had a chance to Castle kingside thank
you Nemo for The Big Race Aid
and you come at a great time folks we
are doing a Speed Run game
thank you so much Nemo I will be ending
soon but you've caught the tail end of
the Stream
all right so we've recaptured on e4 we
have this position what does white want
to do on the next move well white wants
to Castle kingside and if White Castle's
King's side it's not the end of the
world but that means we're not you know
that means our our entire strategy of
pressuring the e-file has resulted in
Failure so we need to try to prevent
white from castling
at all costs now we can do it without
sacrificing anything by using our Queen
we can play Queen E7 or we can play
Queen E8 now if you're experiencing the
king's Indian you will know that Queen
E8 is often a better move than Queen E7
on E7 the queen is vulnerable to various
types of unpleasant moves like D6 Bishop
G5 comes with Tempo so there's various
shenanigans that affect the queen when
it's on E7 and E8 is a very typical
Square for the queen in the king's
Indian you see this in in a wide variety
of different lines so we play Queen E8
we prevent white from castling because
if White Castles he loses the bishop
so my guess is something like King F2 is
probably White's best bet but then
perhaps we'll develop our light squared
Bishop to G4 our dark squared Bishop has
a nice D4 square that it's aiming at I
wouldn't put the bishop there just yet
there's a knight on F3 they can capture
it but maybe one idea would be to play
Bishop G4 trade it for the Knight and
then establish the other Bishop on D4
potentially with check if White's King
lands on F2 Knight G5 so our opponent
doesn't back down
Knight G5 is a very ambitious move
trying to chase The Rook off of the
e-file and guarantee the ability to
Castle so again I see two options again
I see two options one option is to play
the move her Rook to D4 which comes with
Tempo and then following that we can
play Bishop G4 we can also win a pawn we
can play Rook takes C4 exploiting the
pin the downside of Rook takes C4 is
that it allows white to Castle Rook
takes C4 castles then we'll go Rook D4 I
think in both cases black is clearly
better Rogue D4 is the move that you
should play if you want to go for
checkmate Rook takes C4 is the more
materialistic option
we're going for checkmate we're playing
very much in the spirit of the king's
Indian I don't know perhaps the engine
is laughing at me
but we're gonna try to go for our
opponent's throat here with Rook D4
okay Queen B3
now
well if we play Bishop G4 prematurely if
we play the move here white has this
unpleasant response Queen B3 to E3
throwing Our Queen off of E8 and again
the battle revolves around preventing
white from castling
I have a cool idea
Bishop G4 we also need to consider
Bishop E3
so the alternative to Bishop G4 is H6
Knight F3 and then Rook back to E4 to
re-establish the pin against the bishop
on E2 I think that's a much I think
that's a much simpler option I think
it's it's it's no frills right we just
go H6 we chase the Knight back we play
rookie four and then we can develop the
bishop to G4 I'll show you guys a little
bit of my intuitive calculations after
the game
my guess is that Bishop G4 is also very
very strong here but I think H6 is a
little bit less calculation required
right it's it's it's more
straightforward
so Christopher Reid asks is A5 A4 any
good absolutely if you can combine it
with A3
then that puts tremendous pressure on
the B2 Pawn chances are our Rook will be
out of D4 by that point so absolutely A5
A4 A3 is a standard fare in these types
of positions but it is a little bit slow
right it takes you can say two or three
moves depending on how you look at it
and right now our attention is focused
squarely on the e-file right the battle
revolves around only one thing it's easy
to follow we want to prevent white from
castling we want to drive whites King
out into the center we want to induce a
move like King F2 and then we want to go
after the king's throat
that doesn't mean that if White Castles
the game is over we lose right our
position is structurally quite sound so
if White Castles it's you know the game
goes on which is what's great about this
position right it's it's it's it's like
a battle where only one side can win if
White Castles the game goes on if we
prevent white from castling then we win
and as I've said many many times players
in the 2100 range they tend to panic
when they're faced with sustained
pressure for five moves or more and this
is already a very very bad move that was
a bad move Bishop B3 why is it bad
because it allows black to get two
pieces for a rook which in the middle
game is absolutely crushing in the
majority of cases this is a panic move
we simply take the Knight and what's
ironic about this is that after we take
back we achieve our dream of getting the
bishop to D4 and we prevent white from
castling so we've succeeded and we've
gotten a big material advantage and
we can now get our Bishop to G4 as we
had planned all along
yeah now it's time for Bishop G4 and
notice that B2 is also potentially
hanging but we're not going to go after
the B2 Bond we are going to continue
hammering white mercilessly down the
e-file until there's nothing left
yeah okay so our opponent is just total
in total panic mode just like totally
you know giving away all their pieces
yeah this is this is not very serious I
think we can just take on E2 with a fork
we can take on E2 with a 4K Queen B7
one more demon to slay and here I think
what the doctor orders is a quiet move
right don't panic here with black and
say oh my God you know the Rook is
hanging and now I got to do all this
calculation just think logically okay if
we take White's Rook then white take
takes our rook and we want to avoid that
scenario how can we avoid that scenario
well we can do so by defending our Rook
we can't defend our Rook directly
but we can play the simple move Knight
D7 to open up a connection between the
queen and the Rook of course Bishop
takes Rook is also completely winning
maybe even better than Knight t7 but
Knight D7 is the simple approach
and one important detail is that well
two important details if white plays the
move rookie one you might say oh but
then I can't take White's Rook we would
have had the Intermezzo Bishop E3 check
okay Rook takes D4 we can choose which
Rook we want to take let's take this one
because this gives us a past pawn and
this gives us the ability to give a
check on E3
which I think is going to Simply end the
game there it is
yeah our opponent lost lost his mind
let's go over the game quickly so the
four pawns attack this game is not
exactly a you know loud advertisement
for the four pawns but
you know dangerous lines like these are
double-sided you have to know how to
play them accurately if you want to
inflict maximum pain on your opponent so
E5 is a sideline the main move is C5 the
main move is C5 and then if you're
familiar with King's Indian Theory
you might know that the main main line
is D5 Black Goes E6 or the benoni style
now white plays Bishop B2 there is a
trade and you get this sort of
benoni-like position where white has a
big Center but it's also an overextended
Center so a lot of theory here there's
Knight bd7 there's rookie there's even
beef the immediate B5 is a move which is
sort of fallen out of fashion uh the
idea is that Bishop takes B5 runs into
the very pretty tactic Knight takes C4
Knight takes C4 Queen A5 check might say
oh I come back to C3 and defend the
bishop but no
Bishop takes C3 and queen takes B5 and
black is much better
so a lot of theory here I won't delve
too deeply into it
the movie 5 is one of those lines that
people tend to not study with white and
we saw that here
so in this position Knight takes E5 is
actually a very serious mistake
accepting this quote-unquote sacrifice
is a very bad idea you could see why the
best move really the only move is to
play D5
uh and here white is better the
theoretical assessment of this line is
an edge for wipe that doesn't mean you
can't play it with black
uh and I have found that
these types of positions a lot of white
players struggles and the move that I
have been playing here with black is C5
what does C5 do well what C5 does is it
it it solidifies and dries up the center
and I've pointed out this D6 Square what
are we going to put on that square what
is like the very traditional idea what
is the best piece to put on that square
is it the queen
who can tell me
it's the night it's then the king yeah
it is the night and this is an idea that
was hammered into my head when I was
around 2100 so don't feel bad if you
don't know this uh nimsovich was really
the first one to formulate this this is
what's called a blockading square the
pawn a blockading score is a square in
front of a past Pawn doesn't always have
to be a past spawn but uh usually and
blockading square is best occupied by a
knight it's just because the Knight as
nimsovich wrote can multitask it can
both immobilize the pawn but because it
can jump over other pieces it's not
restricted by the pawn as for example a
queen would right if you put a queen on
D6 the queen would just be staring at
the pawn that would be a very good use
of resources but the Knight is going to
be putting pressure on C4 and E4 while
also blockading the pawn so I remember I
had a game in the world youth Under 12
which I ended up winning but
the one game that I lost had a very
instructive moment
that my coach just excoriated me for so
this was the critical position
you should immediately see the
similarity this was actually a perk
which I used to play at the time
so I correctly understood that the D5
Pawn is incredibly annoying it's sort of
hanging over Black's position so I
played the move that a lot of people
want to play instinctively which is C6
like I want to get rid of the D5 font
the problem with the move C6 is that it
creates massive weaknesses on the queen
I mean look at the structure and very
quickly white just pounced on me and
never let go and won the game pretty
straightforwardly what would have been
the best move yeah as you guys are
already pointing out very impressive
Knight F6 to E8 is the strongest move
with the idea of rerouting the Knight to
D6 for example if white plays H3 I would
even conserve the bishop here with
Bishop D7 then your idea is to play
Knight D6 and the byproduct of this is
that not only the D5 Pawn is blockaded
but also you now have the typical King's
Indian idea of pushing F5 and shattering
the pawn chain
so
night is the best block Gator and when
there's a Pawn on D5 like this you often
want to put a knight on D6
now in the context of the king's Indian
line
this is not all like peaches and
cherries white is better here and Bishop
G5 is a very strong move that prevents
98. so you can analyze this a little bit
on your own C5 is not the main line the
most popular move is nbd7 Bishop D3
and now if I remember correctly the
stockfish recommendation is actually C6
to open up a pathway for the queen to B6
you can analyze this on your own if
you're interested so if you're a Kings
Indian player this is definitely a line
that you can take under consideration
but but I think you should learn C5 if
you want to know what to play against
the four pawns you should learn C5
and I'll give you a little hint the best
move in this position is actually a very
rare move Knight beat a D7
this is very rare but it is now what all
of the top GMS play and the idea is
after castles you play rookie 8 and if
Knight D2 you push C4 sacking the pawn
in order to get the C5 Square for the
knight in black gets a very big
initiative in this line
so this is throwing the four pawns into
us into serious question so E5 takes
takes white plays Knight takes E5 we
push C5 in order to shatter the center
and weaken the Knight
D5
and rookiee which I can now see is
actually the best move
Knight F3 so the alternative was to play
94-94
then perhaps we can throw in a check on
H4 forcing the Knight back and then play
Bishop takes C5 and here I think black
is also clearly better I mean you could
just visually visually you can see that
white is struggling with development and
tons of weaknesses but this was a
completely viable alternative but rookie
8 is even stronger
Knight F3 Knight takes C4
94 rookie four
what's funny is that Rook takes C4 is
actually an inaccuracy according to the
engine this is a good great example of
like the gulf between engine thinking
and human thinking
99.9 of people would take on e4
automatically but there is an even
stronger move who can find it if you're
watching on YouTube pause the video see
if you can find
this really funny looking move that's
even stronger than Rook takes C4 so it's
not Queen A5 check although that's an
interesting suggestion because of Bishop
D2 that doesn't yield anything
okay so there's two main suggestions F5
and Bishop F5 one of them is Right
Bishop F5 is wrong because after Bishop
D3
you're actually helping White Castle
remember the ultimate goal is to prevent
white from castling
the move is the F5
now you might say well but I don't get
how this prevents white from castling
well I can play Bishop E2 white can't
play Bishop D3 because now you take with
a fork but the thing is after Bishop E2
you take with the pawn and this Pawn is
a monster it's attacking the Knight the
Knight has no good squares because the f
file is open and White's position
collapses I mean where is the Knight
going to go
if the Knight drops back to D2 oh my God
the top engine move okay it's no longer
the top engine move but Bishop H3 was
recommended at one point
which is totally Wild
um well the idea this is actually a a I
wouldn't say a well-known idea but it's
a an idea that I have seen before you
force she takes H3 and you play Queen H4
check let's see if I can find an example
of this IRL
no yeah it'll be hard so I'll save that
for another day
but I have seen similar types of ideas
you force she takes stage three Queen H4
and now Bishop D4 leads to Checkmate on
F2 the point is that you if you play the
immediate Queen H4 then white has G3
does that make sense
but the best move here is is simply
Bishop D4 to prevent castling you are
familiar with this move by now
and if Knight B3 then you support the
bishop with Queen F6 threatening a
devastating check on F2
and after Knight takes D4 C takes D4
just look at these two Pawns
these two pawns are going to tear white
apart you're going to play D3 and E3 and
E2 and this game is totally over so F5
is a fascinating move I
was completely oblivious to it I wasn't
even thinking about it we took on e4 and
of course black is still better here
there's no question that black is better
but I think that our opponent could have
minimized or Limited at the very least
our advantage by tucking the king away
on F2 which is a better Square than E1
our opponent tried to solve his problems
manually with the move Knight G5 the
problem is white is just not able to
afford a move like this he's got too few
pieces developed and this gives us the
D4 Square so the best move oops sorry
the best move here was definitely King
F2 but it's a You could argue it's a GM
move but you understand the point of it
you want to play rookie one and
eventually you want to Castle by hand
right I mean you have to compromise when
you're in trouble in these types of
situations we would have probably played
Bishop G4 which was my idea and then the
line that I was calculating was H3
Bishop F3 Bishop F3 and now we establish
this monster Bishop on D4
and we force the king back to F1
King G3 gets mated to Queen E5 Chuck
so white has to drop the king back and
okay the engine gives like a small Edge
for black I think in Practical terms
White's position is incredibly difficult
to handle because everything is
disconnected and the king is still weak
so that would be one option
another option would just be to play the
calm developing move Knight D7 and the
idea of this move is really fascinating
this position you can play Knight F6
sacrificing The Exchange on your own
terms Bishop B4 Knight takes C4 again
you force the king back to F1 closing
off the rook and now bang you can strike
on the queen side you should be able to
tell that white is under tremendous
amount of attack here so lots of options
for black even after King F2 but this
would have kept wide in the game Knight
G5 now Rook D4
this is better than Rook take C4 I think
Queen B3 and simply H6
I I'm confident that Bishop G4
was also a very very powerful move
perhaps even the best move
calicash says I would never guess any of
these moves but if you're not
understanding the intention behind them
then stop me and make me repeat it
because you should be looking at this
and saying well these are complicated
moves but I understand why they're being
played the one thing I wanted to show
you here the reason I initially rejected
Bishop G4 is because of no not because
of that because of Queen E3
why is Queen E3 annoying well it's
actually a very annoying move because if
you trade Queens not only are you taking
the foot off the gas pedal but the Rook
is literally trapped on D4 black loses
they might say well no problem just
gonna not trade Queens but if you don't
trade Queens then white is now ready to
Castle kingside if you play a move like
Queen D7 then white is ready to Castle
Kingston and he solved all his problems
but black has an incredibly powerful
move it's what I would call a GM move
it's not one of those moves that wins
you the brilliancy prize but it's the
kind of move that wins you the game who
can find the best move for black again
pause the video here if you're watching
on YouTube see if you can spot the best
way to keep the tension
yeah most of you guys are very close so
it is a night move yeah Knight A6 is
very strong Knight D7 is the best move
just keep the Knight closer to the
center you simply connect the queen and
the Rook why is this move so strong
because now if white takes the queen
himself or herself then Rook takes E8
attacking the bishop Knight F3 Rook D4
and even with the absence of the Queens
the bishop is still lost
um and a lot of people they they still
tend to make the assumption that whence
when Once once or when the Queens come
off the board the attack automatically
Ends don't make that assumption you can
Checkmate the king with two Rooks and
three minor pieces you can even
Checkmate the king with basically one
minor piece
so Knight D7 connects the rook and the
Queen and black says I'm happy to trade
Queens but you're gonna have to give up
your Bishop on E2 in the process I could
say well no problem let me just take on
G4
and after Rook takes G4 let me just
Castle can't do that either because of
Bishop D4 with a pin
what you can do is take the queen in
this position and while you don't lose
the bishop on E2 you lose a million
other things after Rook takes C4 black
is just tearing white apart white can't
move a muscle without losing another
Pawn a rook is coming into C2 this game
is over
does that make sense
so these moves that keep the tension are
very important of course Knight A6 same
exact idea is I can see almost the same
evaluation
why is this a GM mobile I think it's not
the easiest move to play Maybe I'm Wrong
maybe it's obvious I I feel like people
always struggle with moves that you know
that keep the tension in this way
but if you found it easy then more power
to you that's that's a good thing
all right
is there something wrong with Queen A5
well the problem with Queen E5 is that
you are not putting a rook on the e-file
right let's compare this position
and this position which Queen trade is
more favorable to Black well it's
obviously this one because here there's
a rook on E8 to attack the bishop after
Queen E5 this bishop on E5 is a dud and
in fact after Bishop E3 we transpose to
the line that we were just analyzing
where the Rook is trapped we looked at
something very similar
it's basically the same as taking the
queen
right this position is virtually the
same whether the bishop is on G7 or E5
so it's the right concept to trade on
your own terms but you got to do it in a
better way
now when I ask you to find the move it's
it's not always a crazy idea and you
should get into the habit of finding
relatively mundane moves but the moves
that still win games okay so in any case
let's get back to the game
Queen B3 we played H6 which is I think
also perfectly fine and Bishop E3 is a
terrible move this loses the game on the
spot of course White had to play Knight
F3 our opponent panicked when he saw
that The Rook was coming back to E4 but
white Carries On
light carries on with Queen C2
and after Bishop F5 the position is
horrendous but even here I can play King
F2
and there's no clear discover check
against the queen because remember Rook
takes you to the queen takes on E2 and
you're no longer attacking the queen so
that's not valid
I guess black and play a move like B5 or
maybe Knight A6 yeah the eval is like
plus two
so white should not be able to survive
this for very long but I Bishop E3
simply accelerates defeat at this point
we have a huge material advantage we
have the bishop and the game is over the
rest is easy Rook F1 Bishop G4
yeah and and okay giving up a third
piece was also unnecessary but even if
flight had gone Queen C2 we would have
played the move Knight A6 heading for B4
after A3 Drive the queen up to E5
attacking H2 attacking B2 but mainly
preparing rookie 8 and picking off the
bishop on E2
can we win the game in this very simple
way yeah they're after that everything
was easy Bishop B2 Queen b797
last comment if white would have played
Rook fe1 what I was saying is that we
have this intermediate check on E3 to
close the e-file so that after King B1
we can simply take the rook and at best
or at worst we emerge with two extra
pieces and a mating attack down the B
file
is Rook takes C4 instead of Rook T4
viable with the bishopins yes it is
viable I even talked about it right if
you were listening during the game I was
I mentioned that this is the more
materialistic option but it tore my
heart out to let White Castle even
though this position I think is still
incredibly good for for black the queen
is attacked if Queen C2 we can play
Bishop F5 so
it's largely a matter of taste and I
always choose the line as you know that
aims for the attack
another question by Jake's was Queen E3
possible instead of Knight D7
well I talked about that Queen takes E3
is a bad Queen trait why can't white
play rookie 1 after Bishop E2
why can't white play rookie one after
Bishop E2 well of course white can but
it's the same it's the same thing we can
give a bishop E3 check or you can give
Queen E3 check forcing the queen trade
and then simply take the Rook on D1 and
again you're gonna be up two minor
pieces
Devon asks what if White Castles after
Queen e397 great question let's take a
look so this is the
the line Queen E3
97 so this is Bishop G4 through Knight
D7 if White Castle's here
then you give up the bishop on E2 notice
that the queen is x-ray defending the
bishop right this is a classic ghost
like the queen 93 is almost a ghost and
the queen defends the bishop so if you
Castle immediately you lose the bishop
if you Castle here you lose the queen
and if you take the queen and Castle
then again you lose the bishop
and that's about it folks I think I'm
gonna head out guys I'll see everybody
later
[Music]